what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so because the century is getting
his own solo series as part of Marvel
Fresh Start which is kind of weird
because the century hasn't had his own
solo series since his original mini
series as part of model nights ah but
because of the fact that's happening
I've had a lot of people who have asked
me for as much information as I can give
them about the century now here's the
funny thing Robert Reynolds original
miniseries uh you know basically this
century by apology ins and J Lee that
was part of Marvel nights and really it
was a story out of continuity at least
it was kind of treated that way for the
most part when Marvel had their whole
comic bus to the 1990s and you had like
avi arad and Ike Perlmutter and those
guys who showed up and bankrolled Marvel
and they hired Joe Quesada and Joe
Quesada became editor-in-chief one of
the reasons why casada became
editor-in-chief was because of the fact
that alongside Jimmy palmy Adi
Quezada basically had a company called
event publishing and what he did is it
allowed for Marvel to basically contract
out lower selling characters to
basically you know sit down and say it
doesn't make sense to spin all this time
and money focusing on publishing stories
about characters that aren't guaranteed
to sell especially when we're in the
midst of like barely staying afloat and
so with event publishing Marvel Knights
was launched and it's sort of the
purpose of again you know kind of
writing about these lower selling
characters but at the same time creating
new things this century was just kind of
written as a guy who was the original
superhero basically he was the guy who
inspired like spider-man in the
Fantastic Four and he was incredible
Hulk's friend and so on and so forth but
somewhere along the line a villain
called the void showed up on the scene
and basically started attacking
everything and it wasn't until the end
of the story that you learned that the
void in the century were the same person
that the void was basically the evil
alter ego of the century and that
ultimately it led to this history
himself effectively wiping his existence
from the mind of everybody on earth the
issue was that when Marvel wanted to
roll the century over into the main
continuity the question was do they keep
that intact and in truth they could have
but Brian Michael Bendis who is writing
this chose not to now this comes out of
New Avengers and what they do bear in
mind is that because the whole idea of
casada basically looking around and
doing this huge reshuffling of the
entire Marvel landscape there are a
whole bunch of events that were
unfolding and around the same time
within three years you basically had
Avengers disassembled House of M Civil
War just all these events that took
place but Avengers disassembled was
designed to do exactly what it sounds
like disassemble the Avengers to bring
the team to an end and then Marvel
relaunched the Avengers with the New
Avengers line of comics now the
difference here was that it was
basically an entirely new and
dated roster and a basically assisted of
like a Spider Woman and in Captain
America and Iron Man spider-man and
Wolverine and I think this century came
on later on I can't rough top my head so
it basically says you don't really need
to know anything about the century in
order to understand this story but again
I do have a video I think I have a
couple videos unlike the original
century story which is one is it's like
my favorite comic book story of all time
like I love I love the way it's written
I love the way it's done it's so
fascinating to me but this initially
picks up in Nevada and basically it kind
of comes out of the fallout from the
first story arc of New Avengers now in
truth we could have covered that but I
just kind of chose not to just because
of the fact that with regards to the
century he just kind of popped up he was
just there and the whole idea of the
first story arc is who is basically
called breakout and it was essentially
the scenario where electro had been
contracted to go into the raft which is
a prison for all these various
supervillains and then shut the power
down to the raft allowing everybody to
escape and there were some cool moments
you know like when purple man seized
control of Luke Cage and tried to make
him kill Jessica Jones and kill the
other Avengers but with regards to the
century he just kind of popped up onto
the scene he grabbed carnage flew into
space ripped him in half and then
disappeared and that was it it was a way
for Marvel to say like he's here now and
then follow up with it with this story
arc which basically gives us an
explanation of what's going on with him
but again the idea of the century being
here is that it's really the avengers
trying to figure out who he is trying to
understand what he's about and it's kind
of interesting because what the end up
doing is bringing his wife Lindy in now
of course Lindy was basically that it
was a character from the original
miniseries the idea of the original
miniseries was that the Sentry was kind
of at least it seemed like he was
suffering from schizophrenia
schizophrenia slash multiple personality
disorder so not only do you seem to have
two personalities in the form of Robert
Reynolds maybe even three in terms of
like Robert Reynolds the century and the
void but it was also schizophrenia in
the sense that he didn't know what was
real and what was false but the idea is
that when they try to initially sit down
and say hey look like we're trying to
figure out who you're about they bring
in Lindy and then they bring in Paul
Jenkins and that's kind of a funny thing
about this is because Paul Jenkins wrote
the original story and the way that
bindus does this is liz is really kind
of intriguing here what he basically
comes along and he says is that Paul
Jenkins wrote comics about this century
like he basically created the character
seemingly out of nowhere the idea that
this guy Robert Reynolds acting as the
century is around creates a little bit
of confusion because no one knows who he
is and no one knows where he comes from
they just simply know that like he's
there basically what this indicates
is that the characters that Hall Jing
has created if somehow come to life in
the Marvel Universe if they're walking
around even though they really shouldn't
be but what is up happening here is a
century kind of panitch kind of freaks
out because he needs to say look you
guys are all doomed the void is coming
like you guys are all screwed you have
no idea how bad you're screwed and then
basically just kind of takes off but
from here it jumps to Robert Reynolds
just kind of sitting in his home now
this is harkening back to the early days
to the original miniseries because the
way he originally picked up Robert
Reynolds was just like a guy who was
there inside of his house and the void
would visit him quote-unquote and the
boy would like whisper things to him and
say things like you're all gonna die you
know and you know I'm coming back and
you've you've doomed humanity and so on
and so forth and the original miniseries
he he believed his dog was the void and
was talking to him and struck the dog so
his wife freaked out and left because
she couldn't handle his episodes anymore
but it was very much borderline unlike
what in the world was going on is any of
this true as any of this false it was
really kind of cool in terms of how that
happened but in the middle of all this
basically Robert Reynolds is met with a
psychic projection of Emma Frost and
this is when we start to learn how bad
things are because when it comes to like
the superhero community in Marvel Comics
a shield is very much like a a monitor
of Earth they keep an eye on earth and
everything that's going on the fact that
the century has existed was basically
stuck in the raft no one knew who he was
no one knew how he got there and he had
this incredible amount of power really
put shield in a panic mode because the
question was how could we not know this
like how could we not be aware this guy
existed and so in response what's
happened is the New Avengers have
basically assembled the veritable who's
who of like this superhero community
basically some of the x-men not really
all of them basically like a handful of
them alongside like all of the New
Avengers themselves a full shield
contingent as well as the Inhumans the
Fantastic Four Doctor Strange basically
everybody's here now this has been
discounted a century on display here's
the kind of power we're dealing with if
it was a person who was just of like
passing curiosity then it would have
just probably been like Captain America
and Iron Man who would just like knocked
on his door and they would have some
coffee and sat down for a friendly chat
but like the heavy hitters of the
superhero community and Marvel Comics
showing up here and basically being like
we have to figure out what's going on
it's pretty intense because what is up
happening is that the you know Robert
Reynolds kind of panics and says well
you guys all screwed up now because like
the void is here and you guys are all
doomed and that's exactly what happens
the void shows up and like
every one like it is it is csy I love
the voice if the century is written
right he is a wrecking machine he's an
absolute demon the problem is that
muffin literally knows what to do with
him so he's just kind of thrown into a
story and then he's there for a little
while and then that's it but like like
how he's on display here like this giant
fiery figure who looks like Surtur and
is like look I'm the bringer of
destruction and you're all gonna die
like that's exactly how that's exactly
how the void should be done just like
this this immutable almost
indestructible figure when it comes to
just like absolute power because you're
talking about a being whose power is
limitless so I make the most you've ever
seen in terms of like the void being
this you know omnipotent indestructible
being him in the what if story we did
during siege when Norman Osborn had
basically taken over shield and like
launched an attack against us guard and
like the void basically killed everybody
and then took off into the universe to
kill everything else so I mean that's
about the extent that we've seen in
terms of like the full unbridled power
it possesses he can't really take a
character from one universe again parent
to another and say they're basically the
same just because things are a little
bit different but the fact remains here
this goes exactly as you would expect
the other half of this is that because
Robert Reynolds is sort of the center of
this whole thing we end up having like
Reed Richards and Emma Frost who
basically step in and the way this works
is that you have like a multi-faceted
source of energy creating a force field
more or less around these three guys
you've got a spell cast by Doctor
Strange you've got energy projections
coming out of Iron Man and the new guy
Susan storm using her force field but
one thing to bear in mind this is not
permanent this will not last forever
eventually like the voids power being
limitless will just overwhelm everybody
else's energy and then they'll just be
right for the pickings it'll be fish in
a barrel and the void will kill them all
and so what is up happening is Reed
Richards basically offers this sort of
play back from Robert Reynolds himself
essentially a video message that was
created by Robert Reynolds as the
century - more or less kind of explain
what's going on now this is where things
get a little bit hairy and if you read
the original miniseries this is where
some who were who are like big-time fans
of the original miniseries like myself
we're kind of like not really sure how I
feel about this
what is up happening here is the century
basically sits down and says he doesn't
really know what's going on that
basically he has these moments of
lucidity where he realizes who he is and
what he's about but as soon as those
moments arrived they're immediately gone
and so he basically doesn't know
anything about himself he doesn't know
his own past he doesn't know his own
story he doesn't know where he came from
he doesn't know how he got his powers he
just knows that he's there he's
basically a walking
hawking example of an amnesiac superhero
now in the original Marvel Knights this
century story it was basically a device
that was created by like Reed Richards
and Doctor Strange in the surgery
themselves that emanated a constant
pulse that kept his memory hidden away
from the world it basically blocked it
out of the minds of everyone I don't
really know why you couldn't bring that
back I mean I guess you might be able to
argue that this kind of far-fetched but
I mean we are talking about comic books
here so nothing is really far-fetched in
the realm of comics but the fact remains
it is kind of interesting because what
ends up happening is essentially
basically comes to the realization that
if you're talking to you know this this
video recording is from himself then
there has to be some measure of truth to
it now to be honest this is really just
kind of Bendis going through and just
saying hey look just roll with it you
know because we would have to believe a
guy who's schizophrenic it has multiple
personalities wouldn't really take a
video recording at face value but you
know it kind of allows the story to
continue so we just sort of roll with it
and say whatever but the whole idea here
is that Emma Frost essentially jumps
into the mind of Robert Reynolds and
they literally start scanning through
all these memories that he that he has
and what we end up finding out is it
again he's been around for a long long
long time he is at Lisa's it seems like
business is keeping intact the whole
idea that he was the original superhero
but the question everybody's asking the
question Emma Frost has is why doesn't
anybody remember you why don't you
remember remember yourself and what's
going on here now again because of the
fact that Venice is not invoking this
neural inhibitor basically created by
you know sensory and reading all them
and the question becomes what happened
that basically replaces that and so what
is it taking place is Emma Frost begins
to realize there's a portion of all his
memories that are basically being
blocked out there's like this black box
more or less and behind this is the
memory the idea that he's not supposed
to recall what happens and what we end
up finding out is that Robert Reynolds
mind was basically modified by jason
wyngarde mastermind now this is actually
pretty smart by Bendis so you to play
this game with jason wyngarde course
we've talked about him before jason
wyngarde is basically a guy that has the
power to manipulate the five senses to
control everything that you see smell
taste touch and hear and so what this
did is basically eliminate all knowledge
of the century from Robert Reynolds
himself it eliminated all of his
memories he doesn't really know anything
about who he is
of course jason wyngarde did this at the
behest of somebody who's not initially
explained here but the question becomes
what in the world's going on why was
this happening in the first place what
was going on behind the scenes and so
what ends up taking place is that Robert
Reynolds begins to sort of panic and
lash out
because he's basically being forced to
confront parts of his memory that he
doesn't really want to confront it all
but in the middle of all this we've kind
of switched over to Paul Jenkins and
what we end up finding out here is that
what Robert Reynolds had done by
extension of trying to get people to
know who he was subconsciously as he had
basically taken his essence and put it
in a mind of Paul Jenkins basically when
Paul Jenkins was trying to figure out a
story to write the century basically
said you have to write about me he did
it subconsciously Paul jingus didn't
even know it was happening he just
planted all these thoughts inside
apology Ian's mind who in turn wrote the
century so it's kind of a unnecessary
explanation is kind of convoluted it's
one of those things where business is
taking a character and kind of making it
his own but I mean it works for what it
is so I may have you know it serves its
purpose but because of the fact that no
one really seems to be able to get
through to Robert Reynolds what is up
happening as Emma Frost
travels directly to Lindy and basically
snatches reminde out and brings it to
the mind of Robert Reynolds with the
attempt of we need to create a shared
memory we have to calm him down if this
path continues everyone here will die as
always really panic mode and is really
kind of like alright we have to stop
this and we have to stop this now and so
what ends up happening is Emma Frost
basically grabs this memory of Lindy and
in Robert Reynolds when they basically
first fell in love on their third date
when they kissed for the first time when
they were intimate for the first time
and the result is that a kind of jogs
Robert Reynolds back it brings him back
to reality to a degree and so what is up
happening is you end up having Emma
Frost tapping back into his mind again
and basically saying hey look you have a
personality like we know who you are
we're gonna have to figure out
everything about you we have to figure
out who you are where you come from what
the basis behind you is we know the
origin of your powers you took a formula
that basically moved your molecules an
instant ahead of the current time stream
you have the power of a million
exploding Suns quote unquote we have
your origin story intact we just have to
find out one who it was jason wyngarde
was working for two why this was done
and three what you're gonna do after
this and so what she says is you have
the ability you have like incredible
powers I mean just astronomical powers
and you should use those to be part of
the superhero community and so what
isn't happening is he's basically
brought in as a member of the New
Avengers now in all honesty if I were
living in the Avengers universe and I
were looking at this and saying what's
the real motivation behind this I mean I
would say they're doing it because it's
better to be on the devil's right hand
than in its past and so it's better to
have Robert Reynolds as part of the team
so you can monitor him then to like not
have them as part of the team and say
cool we're done here and then go home
only to find out that like the entire
state of California has been wiped off
the map by the void because Robert
Reynolds
episode so I mean is it's kind of cool
you know in terms of like why they would
do that and how that works but it does
serve its purpose because what it does
is allows Emma Frost to tap into his
mind and basically bring out the century
persona to essentially say like the void
is not some alternate personality you
have out there it's not some being out
there that you have no control over like
you can control whether or not the void
appears like it's part of who you are
you can master it and you can basically
keep the void hidden away and never have
to worry about it again now this is the
way for Marvel to kind of you know toy
things that basically say hey look like
this entries here but who knows what do
you might freak out and become the void
again you know that's that's kind of
what Marvel was doing with this whole
scenario and it works I mean you know
again it's it serves purpose it does
fine but basically he becomes a member
of the Avengers and that's how he's
inducted into the New Avengers team now
following this one going forward into
the future of Marvel Comics the surgery
was just kind of there he was just a guy
who was it was almost like a squandered
opportunity like you had this really
really cool character Marvel could have
told some fantastic stories it dealt
with like schizophrenia and multiple
personality disorder but he was just
kind of taking a character that was
created as part of Marvel Knights that
was rolled over by Brian Michael Bendis
probably at the hands of Joe Quesada and
then no one ever really did anything
with him anymore he was just kind of a
background character who would have
liked some highlight moments here and
there that was really about it but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain and make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the robb core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you